stunden der strom ausgefallen ist für
muss man da wahrscheinlich den den
braucht eine ansprache an das deutsche
verlassen in der letzten
den städten haben wir beispielsweise
kauft wächst man ja in der deutschland
fall ein freispruch falsch ist der aber
könne es auch sein übrigens was mich war
sprechen über ihr thema ja sehr
damen und herren bei 485 köpfen sind
hafengeburtstag da war es dann auch die
russischen freundschaft war der fall
legislaturperiode aus den gründen der
eben wieder ich nehme aber war dass die
geht es in den gebieten rund um den
persönlich also ist schmerzt mich
u-bahn in kiew zum beispiel sind diese u
dieser mann aufgrund dieses neuen
der politik zu hinterfragen live
einige zehntausend haushalte das war
innen außenminister stern ihnen noch
bewusstsein bei den menschen auch wenn
jahrelanger prozess durchlaufen und wenn
in den industrieländern verknappt die
könnte man auch sagen ohne meinen
finde schon wenn man wenn man sieht was
schön dass sie zurück sind und wir
ist die rechtslage so deswegen zu einem
volk eine erklärung warum er was tut
habe ich hier ein wenig natürlich jetzt
gebaut und hat aber der lg parade mit
laut der spd nahm einen ist es ein ist
rechtsfrieden
hinterher als falsch erweist dann muss
gesetzes was erst wenige wochen in kraft
grenze des witzes erreicht in der
einzelfall sicherheit und das ist
das wäre nicht richtig wir dürfen keine
herzlich willkommen meine damen und
ukraine hat ja auch für deutschland
herzlichen dank sind ja sonst immer
wirklich wenn internationale presse
meinungen von jeder von uns hat ein
generationen nach uns kommt also gerade
mitdiskutieren zu nahe treten zu wollen
also da kann ich dann ein lauter
gerade in den öffentlich rechtlichen
supermarkt geben übrigens die
gerade vor zwei jahren und dann zeigt es
etwas
hinten anstellen dürfen sich
das dann geschehen ist dann muss auch
machen direkt weiter mit alexander von
vorschriften in dem strich aber
flächen die weltweit für den
osten weiter aber wie schnell russland
ist erneut festgenommen worden ist in
bahn so ausgestaltet dass sie auch
herren und zu fördern der 85 kräfte fünf
einmal minister kollegen kunden sind
aufregerthemen die mitgebrachten ich
bundesrepublik ist es gerade sollen der
medien gerade so im kinderfernsehen er
unmittelbare folgen und wir haben
man auch die möglichkeit haben in der
auf habe acht gehen lässt innerlich ist
thema mitgebracht was ihn bewegt freut
das ist das historisch gewachsen ist das
sage ich mal sehr junge menschen auch
gemacht also es war es war es war also
einzelfallgerechtigkeit ist ein
wegschmeißt quote noch sehr viel höher
egal welche meinung hat muss sie endlich
irgendwann der rechtsfrieden herrschen
fortschritten auf der anderen seite der
titelt das wir als land die stärksten
brauchen nicht ernst nehmen als
nahrungsmittelanbau zur verfügung stehen
dass wir vielleicht auch etwas panik
schönburg tja also erstmal freue ich
wahrscheinlich momentan ich will dem
rechtsordnung das zu korrigieren und das
schutz bieten können dass man also
krise ein problem aber ich würde ihm
gemerkt dass wir in deutschland ein
sich eben dass ganz viele dinge nicht
untersuchungshaft gesteckt wurden ist
meinungen ich freue mich sehr dass sie
dort weiter vorankommt das scheint
man kann ich dann wieder anfangen alles
da gibt es ja verschiedene programme
habe eine schöne entscheidung eines
komplett vollständig es ist kein defizit
interesse aber es ist nicht das
oder schockiert
der kollege ist sehr sehr gut
haben wir jetzt gemacht und deswegen
weil die tomaten eben genau genau wie du
sogenannten experten hat sogar meine
was die die geschlechterfrage und die
mehr funktionieren das denkt bei der
erde menschen sterben weil wir gerne
71 prozent der weltweiten ackerfläche
nach wie vor zutrauen geben wir in
schutz tore beispielsweise dort
gerade schön also panik ist nie ein
also welche sprache dort gesprochen wird
ernsthaft er konnte ich mich vor einem
eingestellt haben und ich verspreche
besser erklären denn ansonsten sind wir
mich aus dem aus einem langen urlaub
woher kommt das du hast du verfolgst die
das hat das oberlandesgericht celle
muss das auch bestehen bleiben der
wieder von vorne auf eine
vorbereitet viele zahlen hatte einen
dringend entgegentreten denn was ist
kommunikation an das fängt bei geht bei
riesiges problem haben beim
vordringliche interesse in einem
oberlandesgerichtes mitgebracht was die
momentan unklar
definition auch das was man wie man sich
so nicht über chat buschi hergiswil
ihnen schon jetzt sie werden es nicht
wieder da zu sein ich komme allerdings
hochinteressante rechts philosophische
unterstützer von putin sind das ist
es ist nämlich nur ein generisches
gestern beschädigt hat gesagt ja die
den supermarkt ist und aus dem container
dieser woche noch nächste woche im
freispruch ist nach der materiellen
bevölkerungsschutz es hat ein
guter ratgeber in der politik finde man
moralischen überschwang mit beiden kann
verwendet der menschheit tierfutter 71
einsetzen kann und das dritte was glaube
jeden tag fleisch essen das ist eben
strafprozess der schon einmal
in deutschland bald wirklich
wirklich rechtsgeschichte schreiben
die hat haben sie ein beispiel für uns
bereuen es erwarten sie die emotionalen
spd seit seit vielen jahren woher kommt
halben jahr die frage meines sohnes ist
ich würde sagen wie schnell russland
verjährung verjährung bedeutet das wenn
wärme weiter und wenn so was im winter
selbst definiert und versteht das
frage ich könnte stundenlang zuhören
bundestag wird sich einiges tun und da
maskulinum kein sexuelles und das
mein problem ich wo ich kannte das thema
rechtslage in dem zeitpunkt wo hergang
durchgeführt wurde und dass herr lugner
ich jetzt nicht dienen ich habe nur den
ich sehr wichtig ist ist dass wir auch
mit schlechtem gewissen zurück denn als
muss es mit heißem herzen betreiben aber
schlaglicht geworfen darauf dass wir
perfekte lebensmittel raus nimmt es ist
wirklich gerne vorstellen möchte da
untersuchungshaft ist rechtmäßig das
ja also da er so gibt es irgendwelche
international der lächerlichkeit
sind sie beides anwälte oder warum also
nachrichten des tages und geballte
wirklich etwas wo wir uns auch sommer
wetten seit august aber niemand von den
auch ich habe mich auch jetzt erst damit
passiert und alte menschen
es gefährlich zur bundesmarine zu gehen
die individuelle schutz infrastruktur
wesentlich gelassener sehen als wir
vorankommt hat ja auch vor allem was
prozent und nur 18 prozent für für
eindruck
diese diese diese beißhemmung gegenüber
besonders tragische und völlig sinnlose
ich zurückkam habe ich meine
nicht mal die grundlegenden sicherheit
ist richtig gewesen da ist gar keine
kühlen kopf trotzdem ist natürlich die
ganze gesetz ist auch verfassungsgemäß
pronomen die er gewählt werden
es in deutschland ein rechtsbruch ist
beschäftigt die zahlen sind erschreckend
preisgegeben
wenn jetzt hier in deutschland also mehr
strategisch innerhalb von europa und der
ist ein ganz ganz elementarer grundsatz
beispielsweise mit so einer lage
habe ich aus vollem herzen gesagt
damit zu tun wie sich die länder
beispielsweise und ich glaube das könnte
kompetenz denn meine gäste heute abend
ein prozess nicht rechtzeitig
würde ich diese zeilen von spectre auch
speisekammer und mein kühlschrank
uns anschauen da gab es früher in der
möchte ich eine kleine geschichte zu
nämlich diebstahl das muss natürlich
konfrontiert sind da braucht man dann
russland in der sozialdemokratischen
also eine wirklich gute entscheidung so
in unserer bevölkerung bieten können und
eigentlich ein kleiner fun fact die
dann leben wir uns doch zurück und
lebensmittel das ist ja absolut grotesk
absolut nicht und jetzt dritter am
politischen parteien traut sich zu sagen
war dann eben bei frau bernburg als sie
und da will ich der auffassung liegt die
erzählen im jahr 1981 das ein ganz
brauchen wir ihn fragen lebensmittel
verhalten die sich deutschland verhält
frage da da passt auch die maus keinen
vegan ischer restaurants aufmachen dann
welt nicht nur der lächerlichkeit
analyse völlig richtig wir haben
unterschreibt wohingegen noch einmal
ausgemistet und habe dabei so viele
angestrengt wird das dann irgendwann
auch im hinblick auf den sprachgebrauch
sind ein sehr kompetent für die
bauordnung beispielsweise vorgaben das
machen sogar richter hold führen werde
union völlig falsch aus gründen der
ja das wollen wir einfach nur freiheit
wenn wir weniger fleisch essen machen
entsprechende möglichkeiten und
mehrmals sagte unsere solidarität und
jahrelang von der friedensdividende
paul ronzheimer
das ist ein erhebliches problem ist sind
und jetzt kommt aber dann doch der
rindfleischproduktion ist der größte
preisgibt das mag ja dass einer sein
schutzgesetz die luft überm ecke
gelten dass da nämlich eine ganz andere
partei deutschlands
was ändert das dann am konsumverhalten
keine verfolgung mehr stattfinden kann
wie sich amerika fällt die sich england
eu-politiker bundestagsabgeordneter und
aufreger die ampel der ist der
zurück in die debatte er kann sich ja
warum urlaub scholz momentan den idealen
vierten juli hat er sein antritt wird
faden ab das ist zu räumen und da muss
einzelfallgerechtigkeit den rechtsstaat
lebensmittel weggeschmissen das dass ich
so interessante ist wenn jeder irgendwie
in den kellern entsprechende
flächen fresser das heißt dass wir
entsprechende kräfte die dann auch
wir damit eine fläche frei oft werden
verpflichtet werden ab einer gewissen
verhält du hast uns heute abend eine
das eben angesprochen war von den
nichts mehr zu tun und ich also ich muss
profitiert weil wir eben die mittel die
unsere hilfe gelten den menschen in der
viele szenarien plötzlich in den blick
wir sprechen hier aber über einen fall
aber ich finde mit blick auf die ukraine
zu schleifen und damit sollten wir nicht
diese grünen roten der darm führen
vorkehrungen getroffen werden mussten
ja ich glaube du hast recht das ist
rechtsanwalt dr jan marco luczak sein
deutschland wäre vermessen so viel
unterstützen können und das was man
selbst nicht einschalten ich bin froh
watschenmann abgibt und für die meisten
offenheit dafür existiert ich meine
auf die fregatte bayern irgendwann
man einfach sagen prozessual und auch
chinesen und aber das habe ich versucht
sagen vielleicht bin ich auch zu alt
jeder von ihnen spricht bin ich immer
justizminister von der fdp und auch die
quadrat mit der größe die lebensmittel
these mitgebracht die etwas mit unserem
getreide oder kartoffeln angebaut werden
wo im laufe der laufenden verjährung
zum nachdenken gekommen wenn du noch da
vielen bekannten 1981 wurde die damals
anfangen ich möchte ganz vehement
gerückt die war vorher vor dem
wir nicht für katastrophenschutz nicht
damit wenigstens die hausbewohner sich
also ich verstehe es nicht ja und ich
kommen und die fregatte bayern wird
rindfleisch und zum beispiel dass wir
ukraine
das rauchen die anbauflächen wir
gründe ist er selbst verantwortlich das
hochtrabende debatten über die rettung
der meinung von dem der spricht gerade
glaube ich naheliegenderweise fordern
schon ein gewisses spezifisches problem
natürlich sie arbeiten mit sprache sie
thema ist heute abend die deutsche
wenn wir sehen die bilder einfach mit
ein bisschen nach recherchiert habe und
materiell im zeitpunkt der
widersprechen sie habe zu recht darauf
da dachte ich mir ach ja die russen
in militärische ausbildung und
angriffskrieg gar nicht betrachtet haben
können letztlich ist dieser krieg so
auch direkt in sicherheit bringen können
die sie wegschmeißen zu spenden kann man
bundeskanzler zu tun hat
würde empfehlen nur da ehrlich gesagt
muss ist dass wir für solche szenarien
grünen die wollen jetzt möglicherweise
die anbauflächen für die rinder
justiz an meiner seite endlich ist er
womöglich im in der ostsee in der ostsee
weil sich beide so plausibel
17 jährige schülerin friederike von
entscheidungsfindung dem staatlichen
mario pohl wo die wo die menschen jetzt
ist völlig klar schlechte kommunikation
des weltklimas und um die füße russen
wobei bei aller debatten wird natürlich
mord verjährt nie aber es ist bereits
auch wir als politiker letztlich auch da
brauchen die anderen das heißt wenn wir
ich habe ich bin zu einem erschreckenden
auch nicht wollen dass man meine tochter
ausstattung
wieder gerade einmarschiert sind auch
insbesondere blackouts angriffe oder
argumentieren alexander
einem geschützten raum auch über so was
dieses gesetz wieder abschaffen die wahl
süchtig fürchterlicher ist muss eine
hingewiesen dass wir rechtsfrieden
wenn es mal großflächiger werden sollte
nutzen mussten an andere dinge
anspruch ist genüge getan ich meine sie
noch jemanden im moment ist direkt also
ergebnis gekommen während nämlich in
wenn wir 50 quadratmeter für rindfleisch
man weiß nicht wo es hin soll er zaubert
wieder dabei fielen nach acht einer
natürlich dann im ausland haben also
die ratten das thema ist viel zu wichtig
sozusagen mit mit einer solchen
menschen in der ukraine und den gilt
ein prozess innerhalb der verjährung
eingeschlossen werden ausgehungert
müller man erst entführt dann wurde sie
jetzt gerne vergessen welche rolle
brauchen rechtsfrieden ist ein ausfluss
ist es natürlich und bundeskanzler da
ich habe heute die ansprache von joe
müssen wir jetzt wieder nachdenken das
es gibt die letzte woche ein verein ist
meinung zu unserer bisherigen diskussion
reißen da eine ganz ganz gefährliche
sagen nämlich das war ja alles an einem
meiner persönlichen lieblings des
brauchen können in dieser zeit an diesen
unterwegs sein und da kannst du mir
sind wir könnten deutschland ist gar
deutschen sprache die es gar nicht gibt
dann auch residente stützpunkte vorsehen
werden sollen dann finde ich haben wir
chance als chance gesehen werden eine
begonnen worden und es ist auch dieser
investieren müssen aber wir müssen
unsere solidarität mein mann sagte
auch entsprechende sabotageakte all das
kanzlerin merkel gespielt hat in der
gibt die jetzt im moment in koblenz ein
ist ganz ganz wichtig wenn wir über das
er zögert dastehen mich alles zu
der rechtsstaatlichkeit und das ist ein
richter heute ja so ist es also fynn
der aktion machen denn danach sendung
linie 1 und wenn man damit anfängt dann
gesamten als stammzuschauer werden sie
vergewaltigt und schließlich ermordet
unseren breiten mehr als ein drittel
nicht groß genug um einen dazu führt
freispruch unter vorbehalt das können
auf diesen 50 grad im leben nicht
um es nur der ard zu überlassen lasst
einfach auch selbstkritisch aus dem
auch eine verantwortung aus deutschland
sind uns ja eigentlich dass der nicht
grundsatzdebatte über unseren umgang mit
thema schutzräume reden was für mich
biden zusammen mit ukrainischen freundin
staatliche strafanspruch geprüft worden
fall wo zwei studenten angeklagt sind
mensch in der ukraine um nicht das böse
kannst du gegen nach der neuen lage muss
trotzdem finde ich man sollte nicht alle
putin umarmung und auch bei nordstream
ganz hohes gut da bin ich ganz bei ihnen
aller lebensmittel im müll landen stehen
brief an vielen stellen das bedeutet
mit sprache so noch mehr stärken als
es wissen bild -kolumnist und mehrfacher
wir haben in der vergangenheit viel für
ja ich glaube wir sind sogar relativ
die beispielsweise in den bezirken oder
dann die wir die wir essen
nachhaltigen klar machen wir ja nichts
mit der maus ist noch zu klein und so
den leuten spaß wir sehen da etwas was
sind szenarien die plötzlich jetzt ins
man hat dann einen mann als ihre
macht sowas eigentlich sprachlos wütend
wir so nicht hinnehmen und ich glaube
essen anzuregen wenn wir müssen neu
wegen des sogenannten containern in
ist eben die frage wo hört man dann auf
holpert viertel nach acht immer mehr zum
ein welche verantwortung was fordern sie
verantwortung jetzt bei einem
wort vom ukraine aussprechen zu müssen
allerdings frage ich was kann denn ein
zwei aber lasst uns bei der spd bleiben
nicht dass wir jetzt möglicherweise
und bis zu ende geprüft worden das heißt
geschaut so beiden der angekündigt hat
das wäre wirklich ein affront wenn man
beste autor alexander von schönburg er
viel habe ich ein problem noch nicht
sich die frage ganz ganz neu beantworten
in den gemeinden auch dann funktionieren
gegeneinander einwurf aber wie gesagt
seinem supermarkt gegangen habe frische
mutmaßlichen täter festgenommen martin
bundeskanzler der glaube ich 120 tage im
tausch der gebildeten stände das begrüße
für ein kilo rindfleisch werden
sie sagen jetzt heute es sollen die
die länder der dritten welt vor einer
an dem chinesischen fleischhunger oder
lernen mit unserer nahrung umzugehen wir
aber aber das ist schon ein thema wenn
für mich ist ganz klar wenn man wenn man
eigentlich fatale ist in der politik bei
blickfeld gerückt sind und obwohl wir in
denn der ukraine ist grammatikalisch
fassungslos was auch immer wir reden
so etwas machen würde einer frau
auch wenn wir uns bestimmte ja
dass man haubitzen schickt dass man eine
morgen in einer gleichen lage sind wie
ist es denn gefährlich für meinen sohn
im indischen sender nichts dran und zwar
lebensmittel geklaut um ist das
wenn der strom oder wenn das gas- oder
hat sogar schon platz eins der spiegel
kommunikationsverhalten von olaf scholz
ich sehe dass wir bevölkerungskreise
delikte seien nie verjähren okay
angeklagt er ist auch verurteilt worden
es ist keine
amt ist jetzt abladen es gab eine
gegenüber den parlamentarischen
falscher freispruch an rechtsfrieden
ich sehr demenz gibt es dann vielleicht
den letzten jahren schon gemerkt haben
den journalisten deren job ist es doch
sie ein problem in der zukunft der mit
über die folgen von politischen
männlich und das männliche soll offenbar
die ukraine heute aber wissen es nicht
zu der aussage kommt dass wir kein
müssen unseren fleisch bedarf reduzieren
bestsellerliste herum kein wunder wenige
netto wenn eine solche quadratmeter
außerhalb der eu wo die wurde ja
stellungnahmen von spd-politikern
bedürftigen zu geben und es ist stehen
gesetzgeber den letzten wahlperiode aber
haben und gerade bei jungen menschen
auf ein auf einer fregatte der
ähnliche dinge ausfallen warum auch
angeht ich finde es spielt noch etwas
noch höhere kätzchen das wäre schön
vorgängerregierung die also die breiten
eigene drohne schicken wird und dass man
entscheidungen der letzten zehn zwanzig
sehe ich dass die haben eine ganz andere
wegen vergewaltigungen wegen mordes er
genau es ganz sicher vor zu sagen
gerade abweichende meinungen zu fügen
dass viele dinge bei uns in der
tatsächlich bringen wenn hinterher klar
einfach genau und einsatz wo ich glaube
bundesmarine durch die ostsee zu fahren
so wir dass unsere eltern und großeltern
vollständiges gas-embargo überhaupt
wegen diebstahls vor gericht absoluten
immer da brauchen wir lösungen
ich kann es nicht beantworten ich glaube
offenheit dafür und das könnte durchaus
zumindest auch der sprache ausgelegt
infrastruktur nicht funktionieren das
vor allen dingen ein affront gegenüber
linien dieser regierung schon gezogen
beherrschen die hohe kunst des
anschauen es den vergangenen tagen ralf
dreißig jahre wo es immer hieß ja wir
meistens herkommen von der außerhalb der
delikt vielleicht ist es morgen auch der
und sie sollen dem dorf auch richtig
deswegen ist es schon ein thema wo man
selbst wenn ich ein delikt habe was
hungerkrise die sachlage ist die
millionen milliarden weitere
selbstverständlich muss das jetzt
niemand auf der welt kann es sicher
aber wie gesagt vor einem halben jahr
kann er wir brauchen mehr sendungen wie
ist das ist ein mörder wir können es mit
ich generell nicht davon abgesehen von
eine rolle in den vergangenen tagen
praktiziert haben und wir müssen unsere
energieanbieter sehr zurückhaltend ist
infotainment sowie er neben mir dr
alexanders selbst persönlich angst wenn
sich erstens drüber aufregen kann
hat berufung gegen dieses urteil
werden das ist falsch das ist unredlich
nicht verkehrt wenn der staat zum
stegner bei markus lanz gestern wirklich
fängt bei der alarmierung an sirenen
hat der hvv merkel in verantwortung olaf
habe ich da hab ich über diese frage
durch das ist ein manko vielleicht
beantworten und deswegen müssen wir als
den angehörigen von mordopfern
steuersünder oder was eben gefallen ist
sein dass wir da vielleicht nicht ganz
sind ja von freunden umgeben die nato
bis zu 49 quadratmeter fläche benötigt
militärhilfe geben will richtung
folgende
deine leidenschaft zu reden du gerade
vielleicht ich muss aber aufregen kann
wieder so viele politiker aus allen
diesem problem was ich erkenne aber
da kann man lange darüber streiten
allerhöchster wahrscheinlichkeit
auflösen
eingelegt das ist dann bis zum
schluss kommt ich kann nicht beweisen
richtig aber wir haben aber wenn ich
gelacht ich finde nur dass gegen gewisse
du so etwas ja ja angst ich bin wie
diese ernährungskrise wird vom krieg in
nachweisen und das sind ja die
das ist ein um erziehungsprogramm ich
sind nicht vorhanden ich habe heute
alexander kissler politik redakteur bei
die ampel hat sich selber im
aber was schon wenn ich eine lösung wie
dramatisch wie er sagt naja am ende
dieser drastik ist für das in duel
deutschland und die freude hier in der
politik auch eine kluge ablegung da
schützt uns die amerikaner haben und
da muss man aufpassen das sind
ich würde als jemand der nicht jura
scholz regiert nicht alleine es sind
böden für unsere ernährung und nicht für
bundesgerichtshof hochgegangen der
dass eine schuld vorlag und deswegen
ländern hier die ministerpräsidentin von
ehrlichkeit und auch
voraussetzung ist ja nicht so dass man
für ein kilo rindfleisch fast 50
also ich persönlich wäre bereit mehr zu
aber nur dann fällig seien völlig in
gerade in der berliner presse gelesen
treffen wir müssen sozusagen schutz auf
mit alexander von schönburg kommt noch
der nzz und ehemaliger theaterregisseur
einmal kurz eingeblendet werden wir ganz
möchte dabei nicht mitmachen ich möchte
ukraine darüber war riesig aber überein
koalitionsvertrag als ein bündnis für
gesagt setzt über diesen abgrund an
verhalten auch nicht ganz sehr ich
grundsätze wenn wir sie einreißen wenn
zwar aus die franzosen haben atomwaffe
bundesgerichtshof hatte das urteil
zugeführt werden muss weil am ende
drei parteien dirigieren also wenn es
studiert hat dennoch ein doktortitel
die ernährung der tiere
annehmen müssen oder oder uns zugestehen
jedes verfahren wieder öffnen kann
ordnung wenn es ein natürlicher prozess
dänemark der ministerpräsident von
aufgehoben und am ende hat dieser mann
rust von der russlands gegen die ukraine
beispielsweise von den 400 sirenen die
quadratmeter fläche aber um ein kilo
der einen seite sicherstellt und
tun ich finde es richtig dass wir
glaube nicht dass realität und politik
nennen doch das sind übliche anorak
sprach ist etwas lebendiges das
gerechtigkeit bezeichnet und ich finde
nicht dass mich politiker so anreden ich
gibt es einen freispruch dann ist recht
man hat wirklich gedacht man lebte in so
wir damit anfangen eine mauer
werden die ukraine verlieren gegen die
sondern die hürden sind hoch es geht um
professionalität dass wir immer hören
ist weil gesellschaft die short
mal hierhin und wird dann über
eintritt von ihm der mir sehr gefällt in
gewährleisten ohne aber sozusagen in
hatte er sich nicht erschlichen hat ich
wirklich das allgemeinen empfinden ist
immer nach dem prinzip der
da darf man kaum noch sprechen hier in
einzureißen in dem moment kann es sein
spanien wir haben den euro präsidenten
enorm verschärft fast 30 prozent der
sozusagen den druck auf putin auch nicht
einem europa lummerland und das finde
verändert sich ja und insofern am ende
wir in berlin bräuchten sind
entwickelte sich deswegen auch vorteile
möchte auch nicht dass die
wir müssen in szenarien arbeiten ob es
müssen dass wir als gesellschaft so
den gerichtssaal als freier mann
träger ausgeschrieben ist ich hatte
große russische armee deswegen muss man
exzeptionelle es unrecht um mord und
kommunizierenden röhren funktioniert
gesprochen dann ist dem strafanspruch
kartoffeln anzubauen worden ein viertel
wenn man gerechtigkeit ob wolken lassen
öffentlich-rechtlichen medien mich so
die lösung muss sein wir kaufen
innerhalb der ampel dass man eine
lebensmittel sprechen eher schön dass
mittlerweile zwei installiert worden da
der kürzlich twitterte zitat von einem
panik zu verfallen und deswegen glaube
sage das primäre empfinden dass ich habe
dass sie für immer ins schöne ist die
also wenn wir hier weniger haben da
erreichen wir stehen jetzt mein wagen
jetzt pandemien sind umweltkatastrophen
die auch nicht so wirklich so ganz viel
überhaupt gar nicht kritikwürdig aber
der ukraine
verlassen weil er aus mangel an beweisen
die schülerin und schüler wissen
gesehen also dieses deutsche beleidigte
komplett andere ukraine politik
lange in frieden gelebt haben das
weltweiten weizenexporte stammt aus der
innerhalb der verjährung genügt worden
kann dann muss dieses gesetz bestehen
völkermord
anreden bitte bitte hört damit auf dann
quadratmetern ein viertel quadratmeter
meinen beifahrer meine sache immer
das ist olaf scholz unser bundeskanzler
tatsächlich nur das was wir essen statt
wir da bist aus seinem urlaub so und
unterstützen dann michael müller
gibt's woanders gut drauf wenn wir uns
ich muss man aber den blick noch ein
ich einfach ein furchtbares versagen der
ich bin sehr dafür dass was auf
ist das teilen vielleicht doch mehr
also nicht auch ihre haben sie auch
wenn das auto irrt wird von außen
jahr von jedem minister muss der
irgendwann am ende gar nicht mehr so zu
kriegs den namen wir müssen nachhaltig
und die verjährung läuft da nicht weiter
also verbrechen gegen die menschlichkeit
bekommt er kümmert sich darum niemand
eigentlich die vorstellung einer eck
freigesprochen wurden das war im jahre
betreiben soll dann sind auch die
ukraine und russland die folgen der
kann man eigentlich nur noch mit dem
bisschen weiter steht es geht ja nicht
hier entlasten kommt es sofort bei
jetzt geht es weiter mit alexander
für ein kilo kartoffeln fast 50
bleiben das sind wir den angehörigen
leberwurst spiel weil sich würde mir so
ein drittel unserer lebensmittel
nicht nur dass er weiterhin keine pläne
immerhin ehemaliger regierender
kann ich wieder meinen seelenfrieden
anderen ansprechpartner innerhalb der
sagen ich fühle mich wie das passiert
souveränen mehr erwarten können als nur
alleine nur um schutzräume und bunker
weil das verfahren rechtskräftig
operiert wird und wie sie richtig sagen
kopf schütteln es sind viele dinge die
denken und dann fällt man offenbar aus
schon vorgerechnet corona ein als corona
alles das was in unserer rechtsordnung
leute als hier am tisch sitzen wenn
woanders bei unter zehn verschiedenen
kissler ja ich habe auch ein thema
politischen entscheidungsträger der
schuldig und das ist das was mich
wegzuschmeißen und entlasten dadurch die
1983 fast 30 jahre später gab es dann
ist hier denn man ist ja ganz knapp
dritten welt sind dramatisch extreme
dass ich widerspreche alexander kissler
quadratmeter für ein rindfleisch das
abgeschlossen ist und diese rechtskraft
sei diese leute auch das macht eine
lenz geht der ukrainische präsident
auf see regel deutschen ich glaube nicht
die bewirtschaftung von ängsten last but
kuba embargo zu machen wo deutschland ja
sondern wir haben etwa bei der
bürgermeister von berlin hat die drei
vergangenen jahrzehnte da kann sich ja
eine aus einer eliten sprache sozusagen
uns fehlen die widerstandsfähigkeit
als unverlierbare straftaten gewertet
das kärtchen und nachher ganz kurz
koalition gefragt nichts woche
persönlich gestern wahnsinnig bewegt hat
den den schönsten träumen der guten
mitgebracht ich wollte eigentlich nicht
jemand einen mord begangen hat dann soll
rausgenommen hat jetzt nicht jubeln
hat nach kiel zu fahren sondern er macht
preissteigerungen von getreide und
heißt wenn sie die wenn sie weltweit wir
keine partei aus nehmen die in
auch im bremserhäuschen las dass wir das
nahrungsmittelproduktion also die zahlen
dass man eins zu eins dieser effekt
entscheidende debatte im bundestag
flutkatastrophe im aartal gesehen dass
sehr sehr ungern weil ich es liebe sein
beseitigt ein nochmaliger möglichkeit
unserer infrastruktur ist nicht
kam und ich und wir plötzlich sozusagen
kleine sprache und dem gegenüber eine
not least fdp politiker und rechtsanwalt
versucht wird eine allgemeine sprache
abgeordneten stark zimmermann rot und
er dafür auch zur rechenschaft gezogen
denkungsart durch einen krieg mit dem in
regierungsverantwortung war das immer
erreichen wird ich glaube das war ein
saatgut die folgen sind unvermeidbar
mehr aufgreifen ich dachte mir nehme es
ausweichen auf die ölimporte man kann
unterbrechen zurück dann mit alexander
hallo die ampel hat das ja nicht ganz
werden also wo ist das unrecht wirklich
ausreichend und wir haben seit 2007 alle
frank walter steinmeier zu umarmen das
müssen das ja wenn du über fernseher
werden das würde ich erst mal sagen und
artikel in der nzz und und bin
aufgrund der fortentwicklung der
drüber sprechen das ist einfach nicht
werden dazu schön dass sie alle für
große meyer die als verstockt
die sie ja nennen dass wir ein drittel
sich hier immer mehr feinde denn die
es selbst bei so einem fundamentalen
gesagt hat ja den schaden vom deutschen
aspekt überhaupt noch nicht betrachtet
nicht wussten befinden wir uns plötzlich
zugenommen so dass wir das können am
ampel zu der ganzen sache steht und zum
von schönburg und dem thema
der tat keiner gerechnet hat der uns
mit händen zu greifen ist nur in diesen
der staatliche jähriger freispruch hat
nicht nur aus deutscher perspektive
das ja sozusagen die zeitlich strecken
hin sei gelassen dann wird es nicht
wenn er jetzt halt irgendwie glück hat
kriminaltechnik eine dna-analyse die mit
hofreiter kritisiert dass sie hier waren
nahrungsknappheit und also auch
dargestellt wird was ist ja auch roger
fertig richtig wo ist die aufgabe von
eigentlich den meisten fällen immer
ohne grund getan sondern es gibt einen
lebensmittelverschwendung bis gleich
schutzräume abgebaut in deutschland 2007
unserer lebensmittel wegwerfen also die
sachen wie warnsystem dass es da hapert
steht auch für sich also ich kann nicht
haben und das ist ja die frage also ich
das kann man überlegen aber ich finde
ende der welt angekommen
aber doch ein prozess nicht erst auf
heute abend da sind und einer der schon
anderen muss man auch sagen es ist auch
ukraine sagen weiterhin da kommt viel zu
natürlich ein geschmäckle also wenn er
in der zombie apokalypse ich habe das
betrachten sondern wir müssen sehen dass
sich da irgendwie durchgemogelt zu haben
volk abwenden den schutz mehreren das
konstellationen soll es geben und ich
seiner meinung und die schöner langer
schlimmer ich nahm es hin ich wurde
sich das angeschaut haben also wir haben
hungersnöte und das kotecki ist und
wir müssen mehr machen wir haben als
signalling also ich rede so toll weil
ganz ganz wichtigen grundsatz in unserem
journalismus einfach die verlautbarungen
verstehen warum nicht zumindest die
eine sehr sehr schwierige entscheidung
glaube nicht dass man so viele menschen
wenn es um falschparken oder ein
erschrecken natürlich erschrecken mich
das thema in dschenin will uns weiter
ist dabei doch und den will ich
finde auch die die materielle
damals schon als als historische zäsur
gelassen es wurde viel viel schlimmer
drängen mussten wir doch schon lange
oder denn der zeuge in dem moment als er
seit wochen nicht mehr im studio sein
die die mit landwirtschaftlichen flächen
ich so aufgeklärt bin weil ich kein
einer sehr hohen wahrscheinlichkeit
wir hatten jetzt vor einigen jahren ja
deutschland eine verantwortung und diese
nicht mal im kiosk sondern in der west
das muss man sich vorstellen wir sind
natürlich ist es für ein bundeskanzler
wenig aus deutschland und ich glaube so
hat jeder minister geschworen und dann
steuerdelikt würde ich voll auf ihrer
haben müssen also natürlich habe ich
außenministerin warum nicht zumindest
auch ich mir war das gar nicht so
rechtsstaat denn der rechtsstaat muss ja
begleiten und wir sehen uns am dienstag
natürlich auch ihrer meinung nur ich
kann ist mein kollege und auch der film
das habe ich gestern nämlich gemerkt ich
festgestellt hat dass dieser mann der
damit komme ich jetzt wieder auf meinen
auch sagen ich würde gerne aus im
ausgrenzen will aber man grenzt alle aus
gefunden ich habe noch gesagt ich habe
verantwortung der müssen wir gerecht
einen bundesweiten waren tag wo man
aufgefunden werden sollte ich auch
bewusst aber nicht selber in meinem
gerechtigkeit das ist auch
seite aber wenn wir wissen dass es ein
sagt man allerdings naja aber
ukraine und hat dann gesagt ja das sei
jahrzehntelang jetzt sehr gut mit dieser
global
schwieriger zu entscheiden als für ein
wieder bei für den nachschuss
auch angst oder sorge mich wenn ich höre
irgendwelche schlimme katastrophen die
werden innerhalb von europa und auch der
die bundestagspräsidentin wenn olaf
langsam macht olaf scholz deutschland
nach acht
interesse der nahrungsmittel
überfüllten kühlschrank zurück und den
nicht nur gewährleisten dass es
gefunden werden sollte oder vielleicht
kernbestandteil unserer
habe den fehler gemacht ich habe mir
beschränkt sind das die
in meiner lebenszeit ich bin 1969
mörder und sagen leider aus rechts
eigenen
glaube dass die aufregung darüber völlig
täter war weil man samen spuren bei der
katastrophenfälle durch spielen wollte
schon ein problem dass diese
ich habe jetzt in einem pfarrbrief er in
friedensdividende gefahren wir haben uns
hospizes paul ronzheimer wenn er jetzt
erleben und in meinem eigenen handelns
leitartikler der fordert jetzt holt man
einen geheimtipp ul angeschaut das
technische möglichkeiten es später
werden schon nicht kommen und wenn dann
welt und wir werden aktuell in den
jeder soll jetzt auf einmal darauf
rechtsstaatlichkeit und ich glaube wir
gerechtigkeit oder auch des weltfriedens
emotionalisiert zurückgekehrt sein also
scholz stand ich will hier her zu fahren
geboren nie so eine existenzielle
einzelfallgerechtigkeit gibt sondern er
berlin gelesen liebe mitglieder und
überflüssig ist viel lustiger als viel
darauf verlassen auf diese
lächerlich the spectator hat heute
vergewaltigung ihm zuweisen konnte und
nahrungsmittelbedarf immer höher wird
von mir weggeschmissen den lebensmitteln
kommen sie haben das erwähnte
reicht es irgendwie dass wir uns auf
hier die ganzen schweren waffen raus und
weil sie gerade sagt wir dürfen den
achten dass er genügend wasser zu hause
fernsehduell zwischen zwei zwischen
da sagt man immer ja das ist ja
technischen gründen muss der frei
um einfach mal die bevölkerung auch dann
auch nicht so habe würde ich in urlaub
friedensdividende jetzt müssen wir
letzten wochen dieser verantwortung
muss eben auch dafür sorgen dass es
besser ist sich darüber lustig zu machen
auf fleisch verzichten das ist in den
zwei monaten berichtet live aus kiew und
mitgliederinnen liebe mitglieder aber
dna-analyse cups erfüllen ich wir sind
die realität verdrängt der
fahre dass das weiß ich ja vorher das
ausländische hilfe verlassen oder dass
hat kauft ihr ein gaskocher wurde mir
bedrohung erlebt das mir gesagt wird du
und der bedarf nach fleischliche weiß
während die dritte welt mit
zu hören was passiert eigentlich müsst
herumlaufen und muss ich sagen habe habe
getitelt olaf scholz wird zum
dann ist die ukraine in zwei tagen
herrn makro und faulen pandas wurde
nicht gerecht und wir nehmen massiven
rechtsstaat nicht schlagen ich glaube
symbolpolitik das sollen die anderen
denn die partie tatsache ist doch die
jetzt würde man normalerweise denken der
umfragen so ihr kennt das aus dem bio
rechts frieden gibt und so trage stadt
wir alle wir colombo angucken die
realisieren das war eine trügerische
wir irgendwie das ganze gewissermaßen
ist meistens ja nicht kurzfristig dann
ist auch heute abend wieder zugeschaltet
ihr euch verhalten das ist katastrophal
doch so komisch dass das ist doch es
wir schleifen den rechtsstaat im
sozialdemokratie in diesem krieg ist
nahrungsmittelknappheit zu kämpfen hat
darfst ein haus nicht verlassen deshalb
jetzt empfohlen ich habe noch kein ich
wieder befreit was wir uns alle hoffen
immerhin wird denn die den ländern wie
außenpolitischen schaden an dieser
machen nein das wäre gerade jetzt so
ich auch ein problem gehört werden und
simultan gedolmetscht und der deutsche
sicherheit und deswegen ist es ganz
wichtigsten verbündeten von wladimir
gesundbeten hörte hörig wir haben keine
gegenteil dann wenn wir es zulassen dass
muss doch jetzt wieder angeklagt werden
feuerwehr hat allen 18 minuten gelöst
in die hose gegangen
muss schauen wo ich den hier bekomme ich
diese gender mainstream aktivisten über
umfragen viele leute würden nur noch bio
schaue ich dass ich wenn ich wegfahre
würden also olaf scholz macht fehler
ich finde diese differenzierung ist auch
indien und china ist es natürlich so
wie bambi nach dem atomschlag plötzlich
auch im einzelfall sein kann gibt es
gehen wir verantwortungslos
stelle das wäre aber nicht mein thema
mit dna gab es damals nicht mehr viel
der muskel muss der prozess gemacht
gibt schon was
wirklich einmalig und ich glaube das
wichtig dass wir jetzt umsteuern jetzt
dolmetscher legt herr noch immer das
einzige sirene in berlin keine einzige
weil einfach die systeme völlig
habe geguckt wie lange hält dennoch
putin das ist einmalig ein deutscher
kühlschrank leer ist oder dass da
wichtig um dann auch die deutsche
wichtig es geht eben nicht um das
dass eben die mittelklasse radikal
werden der muss hinter schloss und
offensive begonnen wie ist die lage vor
es solche falschen freisprüche gibt wo
aber ich finde wir haben eine
hat sich daraus geht das ist vielleicht
olaf olaf scholz hat eine schlechte
aufwendiger also ich würde einfach sagen
kaufen aber es tun eben nur wenige ja
verschwenderisch mit unserem essen um
knöllchen das geht nicht um die einfache
humor machten den anfang haben sie
position zu erklären wenn es denn so ist
eben einen ganz elementaren grundsatz in
riegel das lässt aber unser
meine meine dosen
fällt ihnen wirklich auf die füße wenn
alles nicht gar nicht so schlimm aber am
wort in den mund von den flüchtenden er
in berlin wir können also knapp 3000
verantwortung gegenüber der ukraine und
vielleicht noch ein paar haltbare sachen
entsprechende aktionen einleiten wir
überlastet waren so und ich glaube da
wenn ihr mann ein mord begangen hat ich
drehen gerade so sehr dass sie sich
und werfen wie gesagt ein drittel
kommunikation seine eitelkeit seine
steigt das heißt der bedarf nach
ort
bundeskanzler der auch in der
drin sind also das heißt weil sich
anfang wusste nämlich da wo jeder
das ist das muss man einfach so sehen
fahrlässige körperverletzung oder es
evident ist dass sie falsch sind das
strafprozessordnung nicht zu und das ist
unserem strafrecht und das ist der
besorgen das wusste ich alles nicht muss
man jetzt mal darüber nachdenken welche
wie christine lambrecht sagt dass wir
brauchen eine schonungslose
gelassen das freut mich wenn ich meine
hat bestimmt von flüchtlingen gesprochen
leute gesamtdeutsch mit momentan nur mit
muss man schon schlüsse daraus ziehen
habe auch noch den kopf mord verjährt
richtigerweise sagten was kann jeder
bestandsaufnahme und dann müssen wir
arroganz teilweise steht ihm im weg aber
der wenig gerecht und deswegen glaube
internationalen presse mittlerweile
selbst das nervt und jeder normale
hochwertiger luxuriöser nahrung steigt
die aspekte überhaupt noch nicht
geht wirklich um die konstellation wo
unserer lebensmittel weg das muss
aber der deutsche zuschauer muss
und da muss man einfach ganz
janina es ist ein bisschen unklar ob das
einzelne tun ich glaube jeder einzelne
mindert die akzeptanz in den rechtsstaat
frage ein handy zu stellen kann es denn
eine art ringtausch machen mit
nicht dann soll er vom rechtsstaat zur
katastrophenschutz plätzen versorgen das
ich sagen hätte ich mich früher
konsequenzen das auch für die spd hat
selbstkritisch sagen da ist in den
ich dass scholz muss seiner
kennen aus dem grundsatz des nebels in
nach italien reisen ich habe mich
informieren sollen ja aber es wurde auch
manchmal so forscht dass sich vorstellen
dafür sorgen dass wir dort wieder tritt
etwas was ich als unerträglichen zustand
zerrissen wird und auch national egal wo
betrachtet wurde ist aber die frage
bitte laden wir nicht alle verantwortung
muss für sich überlegen wie keiner
das ist irgendwo muss das ja herkommen
letzten jahren einfach dann zu wenig
unsere rechtsordnung ganz elementar sagt
natürlich erzogen werden es sind
verantwortung für diese böse tat gezogen
osteuropäischen staaten dass wir dort
ich glaube sicherlich hat olaf scholz
heißt wir schauen wir zurück auf
freiwillig gemeldet ich wollte ich
vielleicht sein dass die ampel die
und das ist am ende ein viel größerer
die wirklich große offensive bereits ist
den sie auch angesprochen hatten man
führungsverantwortung die hat als
man geht ihnen supermarkt man kommt mit
können wir nicht fleisch substituieren
mensch finde das lächerlich das heißt
nie vermittelt dass das wichtig ist dass
empfunden habe was glaube ich auch dem
fassen er zu einem ganz praktische frage
jahrzehnten versagen der
weg den chinesen kaufen im moment hat
man hinschaut spiegel faz bild bei uns
bei ihm abschauen wir auf die
passieren viele dinge sind in der länder
wollte endlich das leere venedig sehen
bewusster damit umgehen weil in der tat
flüchtende dann habe ich eine reportage
werden und wenn das erst 30 jahre später
panzer hin liefern und dann aus den
bundeskanzler endlich folge leisten wenn
sich darüber aufzuregen ist eigentlich
drei tüten nach hause und man eine der
schaden als wenn man jetzt in einem in
das wiegt so schwer dieses unrecht das
man sich selber drum kümmern soll und
solle nicht zweimal in derselben sache
wahlperiode der umerziehung wird
rechtsempfinden der allermeisten
sicherheitspolitik wenn man wirklich
afrika auf aber nicht nur um dort um
aber ich sag euch wir hatten die diese
verantwortung aber natürlich muss der
das belastet uns auch alle wenn wir
also russland schießt mit artillerie mit
teilweise recht dass die deutschen
oder auch anders herstellen da sind ja
gehört im bayerischen fernsehen im
osteuropäischen staaten wirklich viele
der vom staat fühle ich mich wirklich
ist aber dennoch eine gerechte strafe
überflüssig wenn man wenn man wenn man
menschen in unserem land widerspricht
drei typen schmeißt man gleich geld so
überall heftige kritik an bundeskanzler
dachte alles um uns herum sind lieb alle
bund auch sein teil dazu trage neben der
einer besonderen situation in einem
sich mehr als bürgerin direkt auf streng
nicht nur verurteilt werden sondern es
jetzige ampel regierung und nehmen wir
ist noch nicht einmal verliert das kann
sie mich heute fragen würden was ist
bilder sehen in afrika an anderen
wahlperiode der umerziehung das glaube
gentechnisch schon vielleicht den joker
sicherlich zurückhaltend sind was
allein gelassen an der stelle also ich
panzer her kommen dann ist das ja
ist würde ich sagen diese 20 jahre und
ist so ist die lage
dort zu bauen oder was die bauen die die
bayrischen radio da ging es um streik in
schon hört an wohnende ist das doch es
cs oder absolut ich werde deswegen muss
eigentlich die deutsche position beim
man in 50 jahren immer noch anklagen
brauchen wir mehr bunker bunker sind
bitte auch ernst ist eine sehr sehr
und deswegen haben wir als die csu
einzelfall aber in einer besonderen
dieses gefühl eine existenzielle krise
soll auch in zwei mal kein prozess gegen
sind nett und die größten probleme die
zum einen liegt das daran dass viel zu
was kann jeder einzelne tun und
stellen der welt wo die menschen hungern
thema lieferung von schweren waffen
schwere waffen angeht aber was viele
weiter zwischen hat er nicht verdient
ich nicht das ist auch nicht der
situation die klar geregelt ist mit
fleisch aus dem 3d drucker sozusagen das
fraktion in der letzten wahlperiode ein
der nachbarschaft und es war immer die
schwierige abwägung die nun der
an der front aber momentan konzentriert
bin ich muss leider nur ehrlich sagen
wenn man dann die entsprechenden beweise
ist doch normal sein sprachgefühl dass
kaufen halb afrika auf um dort dann die
man selbst könnte sich an die eigene
anspruch beispielsweise meiner partei
einmal hat die pressekonferenz
wir haben sind vielleicht bei dem mass
kommt das hab ich seit meiner lebenszeit
also ich weiß nicht was tut ein doktor
aber man muss dann auch zeigen dass man
eingeführt werden wenn ein rechtsstaat
hat und in einer konstellation wo es auf
klaren und strikten hürden hier eine
natürlich etwas das man nicht von heute
rede von anwohnenden dann dachte ich mir
nase fassen was man falsch gemacht warum
und wir leben im überfluss dass das
wenig passiert viel zu lange gezögert
bundeskanzler für die ganze regierung
er dass das unsinn ist ich finde auch
index und waldsterben aber ich stimme
die entscheidende frage und die antwort
dass ich ab auch betroffen war von
gesetz durchgesetzt auf den weg gebracht
sind das sind dinge die jetzt im kommen
der fdp also niemand soll umerzogen
rinder zu füttern die die mack
jetzt wird bekommen ist dass es bei der
sich vor allem alles weiterhin auf die
einmal ein verfahren gegen einen bürger
angesprochen ich könnte es ihnen nicht
gemacht aber du hast mich die situation
der für das ganze volk letztlich
auf morgen herstellen kann wir haben
nicht erlebt also in meiner zeit ebenso
wenn nicht öffentlich rechtlichen radio
solche wiederaufnahme des verfahrens
und gezaudert wird denn wir sind in
warum sind ist eigentlich nicht an
sind das sind auch dinge glaube ich auf
in zwei sätzen sagen weil das ein
wachsenden mittelklasse sind in china
dieser naivität ich muss sagen also ich
haben wir diese lage jetzt geld ist ja
der hand liegt dass jemand der täter ist
macht einem jahr wie sie richtig sagen
ich stimme ich natürlich zu aber wer
ist wir müssen unser konsumverhalten
stadt mario pohl und dort hat wladimir
hinter der ukraine steht und dann muss
spd der sehr viel weiter geht nämlich
durchführen muss aber genau das ist ja
was genau diesen missstand ab stehen
werden aber ich will mal hier eine etwas
höre muss ich immer wieder ich finde
zulässt nein da muss dann muss die
alle schutzräume wie gesagt wieder
wollen da gibt es nur in bayern an
auch vielleicht wirklich auch ein
geführt hat und es dem rechtsstaat nicht
woche sieben bei den woche acht dieses
furchtbares geschwurbel war ein
essen will wenn wir da jetzt nicht daran
nur um die konzentration geht es ja wo
schlechtes gewissen aber ich bestimmt
genug da ist die etats der ist nicht
sie waren auch naiv na gut aber ich
ich würde also das ist sozusagen die die
die man eher das augenmerk richten muss
der punkt oder scholz ist in
wohnende nein auch in berlin gibt es an
provokante these in den raum stellen ich
seit ich politisch denken kann seit
sollte was möglichkeiten schaffen sollte
dass man in wahrheit immer noch nicht
man hier endlich mal herfahren und sich
hätte denn vor fünf jahren oder vor drei
staatsanwaltschaft wenn eben zweifel
putin der russische präsident heute ja
privatisiert es gibt keine mehr die zur
gelungen ist den strafanspruch des
krieges und noch immer kommt nicht
es völlig klar ist aufgrund einer neuen
gehen haben wir ein problem und das
auch diese komische
eben einen zusammenhang es ist jetzt
als auf die frage des verzichts wir
komplexes thema ist oder wer olaf scholz
ganz klein wieso stehen wir so
ändern wir müssen wirklich überdenken
glaube ist es immer einfach mit fingern
nehme immer wieder war also wenn wir
verantwortung gewählt worden er ist der
anfang der 80er jahre waren wir im
wohnende und sogar die berliner polizei
pause die immer gemacht künstler innen
bestehen ob man das ganze durchsetzen
besteht ein zusammenhang aber ich bin da
das selbst anschauen ich meine ich finde
beweislage das ist der täter dann zu
heißt das fleisch das sie essen geht auf
diese verfahren wieder neu aufzurollen
genügend hilfe aus deutschland das ist
zurzeit wir waren jetzt gesellschaft
jahren oder noch letztes jahr nein vor
realisiert hat was hier wirklich
rechtsfrieden oder uns ist hergestellt
müssen einfach schauen was können wird
jetzt hier sozusagen als mittelalte
verfügung stehen wir haben auch keine
kann auf der basis der rechtslage dann
deutsche bundeskanzler und er hat ja mal
schlechter erfahrungen haben wir keinen
dramatisches fürchterliches angekündigt
überhaupt wie wir die achtung gegenüber
naiv also vor einer vor einem halben
sind auch ganz schnell einig die frage
kosten dass das der ernährung der
es als deutschland der jetzt seit über
technisch machen dann können wir nämlich
absoluten frieden und die vorstellung
twittert mittlerweile von anwohnenden
einfach fakt aber das zweite problem von
passiert
sagen als rechtsordnung auch als
funktionieren katastrophenschutz das ist
also esstisch steht die neuen binäre
und das ist doch wieder auch er bei
möglichkeiten die von heute auf morgen
gegen erhebliche widerstände die spd
also frei gesprochen worden dann ist es
auch genau abwägen ob man auf dieser
männer das thema diskutieren dann geben
vielen dank paul dass du uns abgeholt
diesen satz der häufig zitiert wird
beim reden zugehört hat schon bevor er
ist allerdings wie reagieren wir darauf
dem dem dem denn der nahrung haben
das vermeiden dass man immer diese
jahr hat mich mein sohn gefragt als ich
zwei monaten hier ist als reporter
er hat damit gedroht dass man diejenigen
gesellschaft den lassen wir aber in
wieder in betrieb zu nehmen das was man
eine frage der priorisierung gewesen das
schutzbunker zu brauchen oder dosen zu
wir haben auch einen gender sprache mit
olaf scholz das im wahlkampf nie so
menschen ja das ist das auch das steht
existenziellen krisen heißt muss man
ich glaube das was der einzelne tun kann
beweislage schon das verfahren führen
justizministerin christine lambrecht das
menschen im unternehmen sich mal eine
verzichts ideologie den leuten verkauft
gesagt wer führung bei mir bestellt
ein ganz ganz elementarer grundsatz dass
bundeskanzler wurde und danach wusste
wirklich peinlich dass der
ich glaube bei unvorhersehbaren
muss man so sagen also ich denke das ist
freiheit weiterlaufen das widerspricht
hat noch wieder ausgerichtet hast kannst
auch sendezeit auflage soll sich mal
das muss ja auch tun da brauchen wir
sternchen mit unterstrich und kern ja
auch denken ja aber ehrlich ehrlich wer
richtig rüber kam aber jetzt ganz
ihm gesagt er soll in zur marine gehen
provokante frage 1 alexander kissler
als irgendwie was tolles das problem ist
wir natürlich auch unsere wahrnehmungen
jetzt ins auge fassen muss sind drei
die noch in dem stahlwerk sind am
will und ob man das verfahren zu ende
bekommt sie auch aber von führung sehe
aufs schärfste bekämpft auch die fdp im
man dann sagt damit ist wenn auch hier
glaub ich ein bewusstsein dafür
der das wichtigste ist ein weniger
österreichische kanzler hier war dass
was er meint der verdient den
auch richtig wenn man sagt da ist nicht
straftaten muss muss muss man da
deutlich wird er hat ein unglaubliches
meinem rechtsempfinden zutiefst und ist
dinge erstens diese bunker sozusagen
zusammenrechnen ausländer verstehen das
er sein abitur hinter sich gebracht und
allerdings die frage und darauf in diese
führen will wenn die staatsanwaltschaft
manchmal auch mit einem mehrfachen kreuz
dich auf und wir hören uns befüllen
stellen gehört ist denn nicht auch diese
der eine schuld oder der andere die
unsere werte auch unsere lebensrealität
hätte gedacht das wird dass wir einen
nur es ist nicht umsetzbar hierzulande
samstag die mario pohl verteidigen von
ich persönlich nichts und wenn sie
auch etwas was den rechtsfrieden eben
literatur und intelligenz nobelpreis ich
die geschichte schauen ist frieden die
bundestag und die grünen haben dagegen
ich habe gesagt ich war bei der marine
alle möglichen anderen hier waren dass
wieder flott zu machen und auch aktiv zu
ganze politik hat da versagt das ist
sich entscheidet und wenn das gericht
das ganze in der dritten instanz schon
freiheit lebensmittel wegschmeißen zu
das heißt man ist von der klarheit in
ähnlich ausländer oder leute geben sie
achter nächste woche wieder du bist ja
mag das sein dass wir dadurch ein
darauf hinweisen das ist ja die gesamte
geht auch zu marina dann hat er mich
konventionellen krieg mit bodentruppen
ausnahme das müssen wir zur kenntnis
gerade nicht herstellt und das ist am
verschwenderischen umgang mit
wahrscheinlich muss man wahrscheinlich
kommunikationsproblem diese
gestimmt die wollten dass alle nicht
ursula von der leyen hier war und das
bis zum bgh gegangen ist in die revision
der ukrainische seite dass man die
richtung geht es ja sozusagen
der wahrnehmung eingeschränkt sind
das ganze zur verhandlung zulässt und
bisschen was einfach aber die leute die
sonst bei bild live immer da und
nehmen es ist uns nicht geschenkt worden
dürfen
nahrungsmitteln zu haben und womöglich
irgendwann mal gefragt ist das denn
weil sie gesagt haben das ist alles
habe nie ein wort verstanden was er
fleischkonsum da ist man ja ganz schnell
schalten das zweite ist dass wir uns
der benennung übergewechselt in ein
ganz klar es sind aber jetzt gar nicht
noch wirklich kein deutscher minister
ende eben auch die abwägungen zu treffen
aushungern wolle am ende und das man ja
verstehen aber wie gesagt ich finde
vor unserer tür haben also ich habe
dann wird diese verhandlungen
bisher noch überhaupt keinen wohlstand
gesagt hat weil er grundsätzlich so
allgemein betrachtet also verständlich
ja das stimmt man sieht ja die
dann muss auch irgendwann rechtsfrieden
verfassungswidrig in unser grundgesetz
quasi diktatorisches um
unser leben in frieden zu beginnen und
gefährlich wenn er völlig berechtigte
haben rechtssicherheit auf der einen
darüber aufregen ist unsinn weil ich wie
durchgeführt dann muss auch irgendwann
sozusagen von der infragestellung des
berichtet dankeschön und
so die kriegerischen szenarien oder auch
haben denen zu sagen ihr sollt auch in
eingehen als eine der peinlichsten und
anschauen müssen was haben wir an schutz
auch wenn das viele fleischesser mich
verschwurbelt inso in chats
nicht mit so was muss ein
kein deutscher kanzler einen fuß in die
frage ich habe den vom halben jahr
fliehkräfte dies da gerade schon gibt
seite da bin ich ganz bei ihnen die es
katastrophenschutzamt geben es muss
im leben zu beenden in frieden zu
erziehungsprogramm einer elite die einer
also eigentlich ist ein lebensmittel ist
infrastruktur hängig wir brauchen wieder
wenn dann dieses verfahren zugunsten der
schachtelsätzen spricht als ob er
die die wirklichen seiner
gesagt die das wird derzeit so überdreht
so hat er seinen verteidigungsminister
herrschen dann muss auch irgendwann
ist es verboten jemanden zweimal zu
zukunft nichts haben ich möchte aber
ist ein hohes gut aber die materielle
fleischkonsums ganz schnell auch dann
wir hören von anton hofreiter von den
eingeschlossen ungern hören und ich habe
ausgelacht gesagt marine das war bei mir
der arroganten pressekonferenzen die ein
katastrophenschutzpläne geben das
flutkatastrophen es gibt auch ganz ganz
beenden muss man ganz klar sagen schön
schluss sein und dann kann der
mein eigentum das habe ich erworbene
nochmals etwas dazugekommen du hast
wir machen hier weiter mitte these von
gewollt nicht verstanden werden er will
brav wir brauchen schutzräume aus
bei gesetzlichen vorgaben wir hatten ja
gesagt keine fliege dort mehr
mehrheit gerne vorschreiben möchte wie
ukraine gesetzt hat paul meine frage an
grünen von anderen protagonisten der
bestrafen was auch stimmt mir wurde
gerechtigkeit das ist doch das streben
gern vielleicht aber es muss vielleicht
erwarte ich einfach als bürger der
rechtsstaat nicht kommen und sagen dass
dass sie sich selbst ab so aber habe mit
person die betroffenen ist ausgeht dann
gestohlen habe da kann ich mich
freizeit beschäftigen wir sind wir da
dass wir den frieden haben tun wir alles
deutscher bundeskanzler jemals gehalten
nicht verstanden wer will nicht er will
einfache dinge beispielsweise wenn der
gesagt du hast gesagt klar für seine
sie zu reden hat besonders absurde höhen
mal das thema renate künast weiß land
steuerzahler dass es leute gibt die sich
nicht jeden tag seines könnten viele der
durchkommen dürfe und gleichzeitig hat
grünen die sagen wir müssen schwere
sind wir natürlich stellt er sich so wie
er dann nach einigen jahrzehnten sich
verfahren ich kann ihn theoretisch auch
gesagt natürlich muss es möglich sein in
muss auch irgendwann schluss sein und
eines strafprozesses materielle
was wir erhalten oder zurückgewinnen
naheliegenden gründen es kann immer
hat und er hatte noch nicht mal eine
lieber nicht verstanden werden als
meinem geld ich sage ja auch gebühren
strom ausfällt ja da lacht jeder darüber
dich ist ist das ein problem deutschland
aber er ist die ausnahme also mir schön
waffen liefern wir hören von agnes
dadurch noch nicht eine frage kurzer
zu vergnügen gibt es ja auch mein auto
generation vor uns oder bei meinen
hat die invasion gefordert hat und
nochmal die sache anschaut dann nochmal
tell okay aber ganz ganz kurz die man
falsch verstanden werden das ist eine
sie wir trinken union endlich stockholm
diesen
dann kann man nicht kommen und dann noch
treibt dieses gendern das komplett
etwas passieren und werden wir dann
gerechtigkeit herzustellen zu sühnen und
java führen weil ich glaube das ist der
check stellen darf wenn man das ich
er den sieg über mario pohl verkündet
fällen wo es um exzeptionelle unrecht
strack zimmermann die vor ort was ich
nachricht er hatte noch nicht mal etwas
wenn der strom ausfällt auch wenn der
strategie das steht auch in seiner in
kaufen das kaputtmachen sinnlos und
und es ist ein spezifisches problem der
großeltern das man halt am sonntag
langsam einziger die these nicht beenden
neue beweismittel mit einbringt das geht
solche sachen wo man den menschen dann
mal sagen okay jetzt nehme ich die noch
gelaufen das war nachdem er ein paar
nicht geschützt ist der hat ein problem
strom länger ausfallen dann haben wir
entscheidende punkt ich glaube jeder
unnötig ist bei der außenministerin frau
was er wirklich erklären wollte ich
fleisch gegessen hat wir müssen mehr
der biografie drin die neulich
unvernünftig aber ich darf ist man
sozialdemokratischen partei deutschlands
mal ran da muss der rechtsstaat auch
jetzt hier so anhört hat man das gefühl
informiert hat und jetzt einer der
sozusagen vorschreibt wie sie zu leben
wer solchen schutz nicht hat aber die
wenn das nicht
also das könnte etwas sein was er
gibt so etwas zu machen und das haben
weil wir brauchen ja für jeden noch
kann und so besprechen wir wären
übungen gemacht haben auf hoher see das
ein existenzielles problem wir hatten
also wenn man wenn man wenn man anschaut
nur in ganz engen grenzen und diese ganz
erschienen ist und das ist glaube ich
irgendwann der ist das strafverfahren
es ist schon schlimmer als damals im
hinwendung zu pflanzlichen
finde olaf scholz muss sich erklären es
bereits am 9 mai verkünden will und dann
sollte natürlich sinnlos und vernünftig
wir am ende durchsetzen können und jetzt
vehementesten verfechterin ist dass
natürlich das bachelor also ich find
vollzogen werden kann sozusagen einen
haben wieder zu essen haben und das wäre
werber genauer gesagt bei der
etwas zeit und willkommen wir jetzt
das problem damit kommt man einigermaßen
das beispielsweise in berlin wo für 31
nahrungsmitteln haben warum und wo es
wichtiger glaube ich ist dass wir uns
war vom staat bezahlte urlaub ehrlich
kalten krieg gebraucht und schutzräume
dinge nicht ewig mal aber und lacht dies
deutschland mehr tun muss und ich kann
engen grenzen hat die union wir
wer die exponenten der deutsch
durchlaufen dann hat diese person ein
kommunikation ihres amtes es gibt dort
direkt zu ihnen sie direkt weiter
gut durch hamburg einigermaßen sie
anschauen was haben wir für möglich in
auch solle man eine sprache die auch
hat das oberlandesgericht celle weil
etwas was ich jedenfalls nicht mitgehen
geld zusammenhang der hohe fleischkonsum
das nur ab unterstreichen ich finde es
gesagt es war die bundeswehr hat runden
alle menschen alles in ordnung aber ich
konnte ich glaube wir müssen ein
nicht der kollegen sondern kolleg stern
[Musik]